[Music]
tiny green army men have been in toy
chests and under parents feet for nearly
a century but now they've officially
opened their ranks to women I was
worried about criticism from all sides
and it was way less than I ever expected
toymaker Jeff Emel of BMC toys in
scranton funded the project with a
Kickstarter campaign he raised more than
55 thousand dollars to fund a new line
of green army women come in for another
shot Steve Hartman spoke to Vivian Lord
the young girl who started it all back
in August I noticed that there was no
army no girls
they don't make them and were you
disappointed when you found out there
were plenty so Vivian wrote a letter
asking toy companies across the country
to make army women why do you not make
girl army men my friend's mom is in the
army too please can you make army girls
that look like women she wrote so it's
very humbling very exciting very surreal
and at the end of the day it's
definitely going to be a time in my life
to remember
Emma's company is now set to release
twelve female figurines in October of
next year just in time for Christmas
every day every day ok with them every
day I didn't know little kids still
played with those little bring it yeah I
love this story been following us and
Steve did just so empower it is
you